hey what's going on is bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I what's going on how's your week been
going oh Jesus that's wonderful
that's fantastic I'm out here in LA it's
overcast it's gloomy it's rainy which is
a good thing which is a good thing
because we always need the [ __ ] rain
out here and I'm so pissed at whoever
the fidon't was the mayor I don't know
who was but last year it rained like
it's never rained out here and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] goes okay you know the
droughts officially over it's like it's
never over there was never supposed to
be a city out here okay so whatever we
got we need to conserve because who the
[ __ ] knows when it's gonna rain again so
what do I see why do I see the other day
I see this whole [ __ ] thing this
video about how to put these giant black
rubber balls they just roll them into
lakes I think and I believe that it's to
try to prevent you know to slow down the
evaporation of the water in this searing
heat out here and once again they're
saying that we're in a drought and does
anybody go back to the stupid-ass
[ __ ] mayor or the governor or the
lieutenant something whatever whatever
the [ __ ] the person's position is that
makes the ignorant statement that the
drought is over so every stupid [ __ ] out
here goes back to [ __ ] taking an
extra-long shower of course not why
would you do that why would you do that
it's not your job as a politician your
job as a politician is not to tell
people what's going on it's to make
people feel that everything is going to
be okay you make them feel like
everything's gonna be okay when when
everything isn't okay and then you make
people scared shitless when there's
really nothing to be afraid of and that
is my cinema on a cloudy [ __ ] la
morning know these people oh they're
there they're coming to get you oh
there's plenty of water
[ __ ] take a nice long shower you
stupid [ __ ] that's not that you know
we're getting towards the end of the
week well why why why would I come in at
you're so in this way I'm a little
grumpy today I'm a little grumpy didn't
get a lot of sleep last night and then I
got a uh I'm going out to Pittsburgh
today I got Pittsburgh and I got
Cincinnati this weekend to [ __ ] towns
of people ain't afraid of work least
their dads weren't and their dads dead
but these kids now sitting around
playing video games tryin to [ __ ] come
up with an app that ain't still working
is it I'm going out there some of my
great friends that I've met in this
business live in Pittsburgh and so I'm
gonna be doing tomorrow morning I'm
gonna be on the the morning show
Randy Bauman of bill Crawford wde so
tune in if you're in Pittsburgh I always
try to make sure that I want to come
back to I do their show because I
remember back in the day when I would go
there and I would play the [ __ ]
Pittsburgh Improv out at the Stax
it's just mall out there and they
literally had they kept the stacks from
you know when we used to [ __ ] produce
[ __ ] in this country and now from the
old steel mills or whatever and I used
to go down there and I'd sell oh about
3035 tickets I mean it was a [ __ ]
hard ticket to sell
I can't explain it that goddamn mall
first of all there was one way in and
one way out on this skinny bridge if I
remember correctly and it took it just
took forever to get in and out of there
and if nobody knew who the [ __ ] you were
it was very difficult to sell tickets so
Randy used to put me on the show he'd be
like to just come in Tuesday dude do the
[ __ ] show every single day Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday I'd come and I
would do it just sit in for almost the
whole show
all four days in a row and then I
finally started selling tickets so you
know now that I'm selling tickets I
don't want to come back to Pittsburgh
like old Billy big shot right I got to
go back there and kiss the [ __ ] ring
then made me what I was initially
and of course they're gonna probably
[ __ ] get me [ __ ] I already already
willing to believe that they're gonna
give me [ __ ] about the last Patriots
Steelers game those poor [ __ ] people
I can't remember the last time the
Steelers beat the Patriots
it's unbelievable these two beat the
[ __ ] out of us when we were kids I'm
just trying to enjoy the last [ __ ]
whatever Tom Brady has left because I
know it's gonna be it's like dolphin
fans they're still waiting for the next
day a marina they've been waiting since
99 an entire generation has grown up
watching them lose to the Patriots and
my whole childhood I watched us lose to
the Dolphins Bob [ __ ] Gracie right
and then he finally retired like oh
thank god right and then somehow Don
Shula still got David Woodley and Don
struck to trade off at that position and
they went to another [ __ ] Super Bowl
granted they lost they still kicked our
ass and then they get Dan Marino so our
lives were [ __ ] miserable for a good
17 years so you know what that's an
interesting question I would love to see
what is the Patriots a lifetime record
against the Miami Dolphins let's see
here Patriots first Dolphins all-time
[Music]
what did I just say I said it perfectly
lifetime record see if we get it here
this is why the Internet's [ __ ] great
this is why it's [ __ ] great
wait what do you mean the pate the
Patriots 111 111 and 10 in the 80s
against the Dolphins it's not [ __ ]
possible wait a minute okay in the 60s
the Dolphins won they went four out of
so they were four and three in the 70s
they were 13 and 7 in the 80s the
Patriots were 11 and 10 I never would
have known that
and then 90s they were 14 and 7 Oh
didn't even do that well against him in
mm we were 11 and 9 verse them I didn't
even know that it was that close
I thought they destroyed us in the 80s
and we won one more game than them and I
thought we killed him in the 2000s we
were 11 and 9 and then this dick that
game we were 12 and 4 all right so who's
winning here oh Jesus 12 and 11 it's 23
everybody I can't [ __ ] do this this
is gonna take forever you know what I
just realized I don't care
can you do give me a total do I have to
[ __ ] think I mean this is the
Internet the whole [ __ ] reason to get
on this is not to think all right let's
see here dolphins 1 17 17 and 10 after 2
decades then they were 27 and 21 ah
then they crushed us 27 and 21 then they
were 35 and 28 my brains gonna explode
here 35 and 28 then they were 44 and 39
then 48 and 51 I believe I just did the
math correctly there 48 and 50 [ __ ]
decades see that right there whenever I
gamble on football we stay away from
division rivalries because it makes no
[ __ ] sense but somehow it's like the
Jets as much as the Jets suck they still
are the bills or whatever that you're
still gonna go like you know I don't
know one of them's gonna get you you're
gonna have a letdown okay play it twice
a year it's really hard to beat those
two times the safe david says say [ __ ]
it's easy all right let's get down to
what I really want to talk about Dean
Del Rey's 52nd birthday party slash
tribute to Bon Scott at the Avalon might
have been the most fun I've ever [ __ ]
had since I got into this business it
was a stand-up show
/ comedy show if you don't if you didn't
see the fly and the stand-up show was
Joey Diaz who should have been closing
and then Marc Maron and then myself they
should have flipped the [ __ ] order
but uh we came out we'd done Dean of
course hosted the show we sold out and
and then in the end Dean went up in
front of this all-star band and sang the
entire powerage album
I got to see Marc Maron play lead guitar
and I got to sit in on three songs on
drums and that's the best I ever played
and I still had a train wreck during
[ __ ] live wire but other than that it
was [ __ ] great and dude it was I mean
I I just want to thank everybody who
played and let me be a part of that Dean
delray for putting it together Scottie
and Nikki Sixx Mike Devon Rudy says oh
just see Dave Kushner Steve Gorman
[ __ ] murdered it on drums Marc Maron
George Lynch I know I probably forgot a
couple of people whoever the one got all
like they got like the the same amps and
guitars in exact gear that ac/dc used
back then so they had that crunch song
sound I know that we've been posting
clips on Instagram and everything in
around the around the internet but it
was [ __ ] unbelievable unbelievable
night and I already knew that I loved
Steve Gorman as a drummer but just
watching him [ __ ] murdering for an
entire hour
it was incredible I still I still cannot
believe that that happened [ __ ]
playing drums and I'm looking up in this
[ __ ] [ __ ] Nikki Sixx playing bass
Scotty and on guitar I don't think I'll
ever get over that people that was
another thing you know and that the
hardest thing about doing that is
sitting there going how though what the
[ __ ] am I doing here but Jesus Christ
Dean Del Ray I've never heard him sing
better you know because now he got
himself in like ridiculous shape you
know what's hilarious if you can somehow
find Clips two years ago when we did it
and
Dean sang the entire highway to hell
album and I believe the next day are two
days later he went to the doctor trying
to figure out while he was still tired
and his levels of something were often
and that's when he he went on this diet
you know his new diet that you know that
[ __ ] guy gets locked into something
and he's just into it you know what I
mean you know I just quit drinking and
then you know eventually I come back to
it that dude quits it's [ __ ] over
it's past him and but if you look at the
difference he doesn't even look like the
same person like two two little over two
years ago when we did the last one he
looked like a [ __ ] he'd look like
he'd been on the police force with a
desk job for like [ __ ] 25 years did
some undercover work he got in a little
too deep and then they [ __ ] they
pulled him out you know and he got rid
of whatever drug addiction he had and he
put it into [ __ ] doughnuts and eaten
colorful cereal that's what this [ __ ]
guy looked like and like you look at him
now he doesn't even look like the same
person in fact he told me the other day
he ran into somebody and started talking
to him and they were gay acting all
weird
and he had to like reintroduce himself
because they just thought he was some
sort of weird fan so he already killed
it a few years ago but uh and he was
horrific ly out of shape and now this
year he was in unbelievable shape and he
[ __ ] [ __ ] murdered it and and I
want to also give a shout out through
this one dude and the crowd the crowd
was amazing but this one [ __ ] dude he
took me back to the 80s when I see so
that the Worcester Centrum Worcester the
Providence Civic Center this guy he had
the long hair not styled at all okay not
the way after a while they learned back
in the day when you just grew your hair
to piss off your parents you just didn't
cut it you know if you look at like
[ __ ] Robert Plant's hair in like
before he got the do in the 80s right
they would you just let it go out this
guy had I guess it was more of a 70s
haircut he just parted it down the
and let him [ __ ] go he had the black
fingerless gloves the jean jacket with
the band patches on it and [ __ ] and he
was head banging vintage head bangin
like it was like 84 before glam came in
and he wasn't just head banging with the
beat he was whatever the guitars were
doing like my neck hurt watching him and
I don't know if he noticed but everybody
that was on the show at some point
noticed him and was pointing like laughs
and going like this [ __ ] guy I
remember guys like this and we actually
I actually ran into him at the end of
the show and a feminist took a little
bit of video so hopefully it was just
the coolest [ __ ] crowd ever like
somebody walked by the line he's like
dude it looks like heavy metal parking
lot meets The Comedy Store it was
perfect so I mean I don't know I haven't
heard of Dean's gonna do it again but I
got a feeling it was so much fun there's
no [ __ ] way he's not going to do it
again and you owe it to yourself you got
to come out here cuz people going like
dude you got to take this show on the
road it's just too many [ __ ] amazing
people that have their own careers all
those musicians I don't know how the
[ __ ] you would get that on the road
somewhere maybe you could do a one-off
somewhere in New York City or something
I have no idea but that's another great
thing about living in LA is all these
guys are out here in LA and everybody's
always [ __ ] on LA going would you
follow defo yeah and then that happens
that happens and everyone was so
generous and I remember afterwards like
I know just everybody was just so
[ __ ] everybody like was literally a
fan of ac/dc and it was just the
greatest night ever so thank you to Dean
Del Rey the all things comedy Network
let there be talk podcast and amazing
comedian now who gets sustained rounds
of applause the last couple dates I did
with them so happy for him it was just a
[ __ ] night in my life
of his life too I should say I'm [ __ ]
making it about myself anyways I don't
know that's weird that was all positive
now that's kind of throwing me off my
game here
I got a trash something now oh I
actually am taking a connecting flight
to Pittsburgh because the only direct
flight is on Southwest and I just cannot
[ __ ] handle the stand-up comedy that
they try to do on those things it just
it's excruciating
the jokes never work at least when I'm
on there and then there's just this
awkward pause and everybody sort of
laughs out of the awkwardness and it's
just I find it unbelievably [ __ ]
unprofessional considering we're all on
a [ __ ] plane that always you know
that's they always the outside chance
this thing could crash as we're going
down the tarmac and the guys doing a
Darth Vader voice make sure Jersey
builders are doing this [ __ ] and
everybody's [ __ ] laughs like their
what the [ __ ] are you doing I'm sorry I
don't I don't know why it bothers me as
much as it does because I actually I
told you last time I went on the
internet and I tried to find people that
agreed with me and I couldn't find one
post
I went through four pages of the
Internet when I searched you know flight
attendants doing their comedy routines
and all it was was glowing reviews so at
some point I guess I just have to admit
that it's me that is me but uh you know
they have an incredible safety record
over there
they really do but I don't think it's
because of those [ __ ] those [ __ ] away
I don't know I almost made a [ __ ]
joke that I I'm not gonna do that joke
cuz we live in a time that you just
can't make jokes like that but just note
that it involved Mohammad Atta
how about those Boston Bruins everybody
they are tied we just got smoked by the
Tampa Bay Lightning 4 to nothing
we are tied four points we got three
games left we're paying playing the
Panthers the Senators and then the
Panthers again to see who's going to
have I guess home ice throughout the
whole a stirred culprits bucket playoffs
congratulations to them this amazing
season this amazing rebuild you know
since we let all of those guys go from
our 2011 essentially 2011 Stanley Cup
team the fact that they turned it around
this quick quickly has been incredible
the only thing that sucks right now is
the Canadians suck you know because I
would be like really excited you know
when we get this good you want to go
play a good Canadian team Montreal
Canadiens team and have a great classic
seven-game series and you know it's like
if the Yankees suck and the Red Sox are
good or vice versa it's it's not fun for
the fence you know unless you're just a
douche bag and you like to see a
one-sided event but uh playoffs are
coming up Celtics it's coming up I
haven't been able to watch any [ __ ]
games the amount of times I've had five
or six games Bruins games or Celtics
games just you know backlogged and I can
only watch the first period of one game
like I did the Lightning game and then I
got to erase all of them because it
takes up too much space I just don't
have the [ __ ] time yawning like the
[ __ ] parent I am right now proud to
be a parent but Jesus Christ you're
[ __ ] and I you know I got all the
packages I think I'm gonna have to get
rid of them I don't even I can't I don't
have [ __ ] time to watch them this is
all good reasons why I don't have time
to watch him but you know I the Red Sox
came out I think we're like five and one
everybody's excited about our pitching
staff the Red Sox who are now the evil
empire and the Yankees are this little
team that could that has you know 502
zillion [ __ ] dollars but the way the
Yankees
versus the way the Red Sox did we've
literally become them but it seems to be
working for us and it's working for the
Yankee so I have a bet this year with
Paul virzi the pride of Trenton V in
Newark New Jersey
Paul virzi 50 bucks a game in the
regular season and I also have another
50 bucks a game with with my agent who
books me on the road so I figure if I if
I put some money on it I'll be able to
you know at least pay attention because
I don't miss all this [ __ ] I don't
become that dad that doesn't know any
any of the players names you know starts
talking about Omar Moreno and [ __ ]
Dave full the [ __ ] Tim Foley Dave
Foley's from kids in the hall Tim Foley
and all these old guys Woodley McGee
you know like listen to that guy doesn't
know you know when I was a kid talk to
still talk about Stan Musial all right
let me read some of the [ __ ]
advertising here and then I got to I got
to get the [ __ ] out of here I gotta pack
my bags go out to Burbank get on a
[ __ ] plane what am I going here who
do we got here we got alright Dollar
Shave Club everybody all right get rid
of all the junk that's lying around your
bathroom they give it the cleaning it
deserves unless you live with a woman
then just continue to joy you're 1/8 of
the [ __ ] countertop in the bathroom
you probably don't really have any
clutter do you freshen it up with you
ever try to like clean up your side
you're a little [ __ ] third of the
house to try to guilt your wife and to
picking up some of her stretchy pants it
doesn't really work does it that was
Michael I was just gonna be I'm just
gonna [ __ ] it I'm gonna I'm gonna lead
by example you can't lead by example you
got to lead by example and you have to
accompany it with loud sighing and then
passive-aggressive what's the matter
nothing what do you mean nothing what's
the matter well you know just you know
you kind of got your stretch
pants all over the oh sorry I mean I I
didn't do it on purpose
um fresh where does that go where does
it go it goes nowhere it goes nowhere
okay that's why God invented the garage
that's the place we just go out there
where you have the stuff that you really
love that you kind of have locked out
there so she won't throw it out freshen
it up with high quality products from
Dollar Shave Club Dollar Shave Club can
get everything they need delivered right
to their door Dollar Shave Club has
raises shave butter shampoo body wash
toothpaste everything you need to look
smell and feel your best you'll get an
amazing high-quality shave every morning
using Dollar Shave club's executive
razor there dr. cavies you know it's
gonna happen I'm gonna get on that
[ __ ] plane and everybody's gonna have
the shades down except for that one
[ __ ] [ __ ] who it not only has this
shade open it also has the overhead
lighting on you get an amazing
high-quality shave every morning using
Dollar Shave club's executive razor
there dr. coffees easy shave butter goes
on clear so you can see where you're
shaving that makes no sense if it goes
on clear how can you see where you're
shaving you need the [ __ ] white foam
to show that you already did that part
of your face right you're saying that
you can see through the shave butter I
don't know and since Dollar Shave Club
delivers everything to you you don't
have to you don't have to set a foot in
a store wanting around the Isles hunting
for razors shampoo body wash toothpaste
none of it you can just eat yourself
into an early grave
eventually your wife has to [ __ ]
shave you clean up you'll that's how
about a round of applause for all the
people that stay with people that get
that big you know what I mean and they
got to take them down to the [ __ ] car
wash you know the self carwash and take
out that [ __ ] scrubber that the soap
shoots out of you know
tie the person to the [ __ ] front
fender like a goddamn mega shot an elk
then you just scrub him down clean up
your bathroom and your morning and your
morning routine with Dollar Shave club's
daily essential static kit but just five
dollars with free shipping you get the
six blade executive razor plus trial
sizes of shave butter body cleanser in
one wipe cherry
Oh Chari then keep the blades coming for
a few bucks more a month speaking of
your next month for a limited time only
use the code Burpee you are are a
checkout to get five dollars off your
second month of the club that's code
burr at dollarshaveclub.com to save five
dollars on your second month join the
club
today right LegalZoom it's a fact of
life
attorneys are expensive you're likely to
pay around $300 an hour [ __ ] that's just
one reason why smart business owners
turn to Legal Zoom sure over two million
Americans have used Legal Zoom to start
their businesses with LSC LLC's and
corporations and more I gotta take out
the [ __ ] Invisalign there we go but
even right after your business is set up
Legal Zoom can help you can help you out
things like lease agreements changing
tax laws and contract reviews can you
[ __ ] do a post-nuptial prenup with
this I don't know are all part of
running your own business do you promise
to love hold and cherish and pick up
your [ __ ] stretchy pants when he
sighs loudly but these are precisely the
kinds of legal hurdles that take time
and effort away from growing your
business
that's why legalism created their
business legal plan with it you get
legal advice for your business from
vetted independent attorneys vetted that
means they didn't take their dick out at
work that's what vetted means now at
least in Hollywood right and tax
professionals available in every state
you can also reset you also receive
access to NDA's lease agreements and
more the best part is you don't you
won't get charged by the hours since
legal zone isn't a law firm instead you
just pay one low upfront price it's
called action legal some lesions have
nothing to do with you check out Legal
Zoom business legal plan and Legal Zoom
calm now and get special savings when
you enter birth at check out Legal Zoom
where life meets legal legalzoom.com his
sons of [ __ ] alright what else do I
have to say do I have anything else to
say
actually I don't let's talk about how I
know how to pack now all right one pair
of jeans two shirts underwear and socks
and that's it
he slamming a [ __ ] bag you never have
to sit there at the [ __ ] turnstile I
don't give a [ __ ] if I was if I was
going on the road for the for a year
that that's exactly what I would bring
never coming home again I don't give a
[ __ ] and you wear black that's what
Johnny Cash wore black so they couldn't
tell he was wearing the same [ __ ]
shirt every day right that's it that's
how you got to do it you got to wear
dark colors you know you start walking
around dressing all flashy all of a
sudden you got to be like Mariah Carey
bringing all his bedazzled [ __ ] out on
the [ __ ] road I always think that
that's why she's always in such a mood
you know what I mean
she always seems to be talking yet also
thinking about something else at the
same time I think she's probably
wondering did I pack those bedazzled
red-bottom shoes that have my face in
diamonds on them can we talk about divas
for a minute you know is there a reason
you know why they're vetting all these
men out here in Hollywood yet they're
leaving the divas alone I mean just
think about how many phones they've
thrown at [ __ ] people that are
probably working for free you know the
amount of time they've slapped people in
the face just said horrible things at
what point
are we gonna hold the Diana Ross's
[ __ ] high-heeled shoes to the fire
that's what I want to know that that's
your homework between now and Monday
when people say that that's your
homework
I took a yoga class the other day it was
[ __ ] awesome
I went there with my wife you know and I
actually I actually I found this this
you know they have fake messed mustaches
they actually now have like fake man
buns and I actually had a little [ __ ]
velcro strip that yeah glued to my head
and I stuck it on the back of my head my
bald head and I went there and it was
great I've noticed that yoga teachers
for some reason they can't just take you
through the [ __ ] class they always
have to for whatever reason they always
have to tell you a [ __ ] story about
how they failed during their life and
then they remembered come busting
through the door hey buddy do you got
your ac/dc high-voltage rock'n'roll 1975
onesie on okay I guess I got to put the
mic down because somebody wants a hug
you have any idea how much I'm gonna
miss you over the next couple of days
huh you know that's why I take the
earliest flight back so I can see you
singing itsy bitsy spider huh
about I can sing you some ac/dc this
morning huh back in black it's AG I bet
you know I'm glad to be back without
loose reduce you know it was that was
the song for Bon Scott back in black
like they were at a Funeral
all right I'm done with the podcast what
do you guys have him for breakfast hi do
you say hi nothing
there you go hi all right I'll be in
there in a minute
thanks for helped me get through the
last 90 seconds to the podcast cutie pie
oh yeah we got all I got all this rock
stuff that I always put around whatever
she's whenever I dress her you know they
got these things I got these motley crue
one sees what is it called okay what is
what's a motley crew one set a shout at
the devil it's out at your mama if
they're [ __ ] adorable what the hell
is it called they're all like these
these cute like toddler puns and the
level of clothes that kids can wear now
even as toddlers I tended they didn't
have any of that [ __ ] when I was a kid
we had like choo-choo trains you know
some sort of cowboys and Indians that
just completely ignored the genocide
that happened that's what the [ __ ] we
had you have all these cool rock one
seats you know today well I need to save
this I signed up for Global Entry you
know the Illuminati one step closer to
make building my [ __ ] robot
replacement when I answer all these
[ __ ] questions but I just got to have
it now that I'm bringing my family and
I'm [ __ ] proud that makes me feel
this to say that I actually have a
family after just being this isolated
psycho it's the [ __ ] greatest it's
the greatest thing ever I love going to
the mall I like going to the park
pushing my kid on the swing
I remember looking at people thinking
I'd always knew having a kid was cool by
you so thinking some level I was sad for
those people I had it totally [ __ ]
wrong so anyways I'm gonna I'm doing a
gig in London England I'm a Dublin and
then over to London doing Royal Albert
Hall which was an absolute dream of mine
and I'm gonna record that night
hopefully I'm gonna do enough time I'm
going to make the double album then I'm
only gonna put out on vinyl after I made
fun of people that listen to records
only on my last podcast that's what I'm
going to do it's what I wanted to do at
Madison Square Garden and the recording
got [ __ ] up so I'm gonna make sure I
get it done right and I also want to try
to get a drum kit there so I can play
during the day and hope they can find
some [ __ ] somebody to jam with over
there
but anyways afterwards I'm gonna take a
little week off over there in Europe and
I'm bringing the whole family over so
when you got a little one flying that
far it's gonna be a friggin nightmare
so it the very least we can at least
blow through the security by giving up a
ridiculous amount of privacy by
answering all these questions that's I
just had to do well you know what's I
had to make a sacrifice there so that's
it that's the podcast once again thank
you to everybody involved with Dean Del
Rey's birthday celebration and all of
that I mean that was just like you know
I I took some video during sound check I
got to put it up you cannot [ __ ]
believe how good that band sounded they
top-notch musicians playing out of all
that gear from the late 70s it was [ __ ]
I was getting like goosebumps I know I
took a couple of I walked out into where
the crowd was gonna be before they
brought everybody in and just listening
to those how [ __ ] good they are and I
got tied to Steve Coleman just watching
a professional [ __ ] drummer it's just
my favorite goddamn pop that causes my
favorite thing it's just a sec hotter
they make it sound that good he was
incredible so anyways I'll try to post
some of that and after we I came down
for the soundcheck cuz I was so nervous
said I was going to inevitably [ __ ] up
the songs which of course I did in a
number of areas but I plowed through but
I wanted to make sure I had one more
crack at it before the people came in
but after we were done with the
soundcheck
it was me Mike Devon I think Josh Z and
we just we just started playing I
started playing subbanna beats and then
they just jumped right in and Devon
started sing and I put the immigrant
song up there and it was just so it was
so much [ __ ] fun so I hope Dean
continues to do that every other year or
whatever the [ __ ] he wants to do at any
time he wants to do it if they'll have
me on I would be honored to be there
because that really was his perfect
perfect my dream of being a stand-up
comedian and then my dream hobby that I
was never good enough to do
professionally playing drums is just
[ __ ] awesome so a thousand thanks to
him all right with that here's some
here's some music picked out by Andrew
thumbless before we give you another
half hour from a Thursday afternoon
podcasts from earlier this year or a
year gone by I don't know what but
that's it have a great weekend your
comments I'll talk to you on Monday
[Music]
Oh
this YouTube video of this week you
really have to watch it okay it's one of
those shows it's basically it's a ripoff
of the view it's four broad sitting
around and they got you know the same
thing you know they got the older one
they got the sexy one and they got the
one who was fat and then got a [ __ ]
stomach tied up like a goddamn balloon
not now she's dropping weight faster
than a junkie right I don't know if
that's true I just looked around him you
know they got the racially mixed chick
and they all got on their [ __ ] shoes
right their little outfits I hang on a
second hang on a second somebody's
knocking I'll let you know what this is
you guys not gonna believe this [ __ ]
that was security and they just said
that they had they had a noise complaint
anyways you know what some rich [ __ ] on
the other side of the door the [ __ ]
piece had one of those really fancy
glasses that they think came from France
but actually came from a [ __ ] pottery
barn if you can hear me go [ __ ] yourself
this is what you get for nuking the
economy anyway so these four [ __ ]
broads are on TV right and they ended up
there talking about that guy that doing
that story you know that story where
that dude got his dick cut off man out
there brace yourselves because we're
about to go there because this woman
this woman allegedly did according to
the Orange County DA's office Katherine
Q Becker is accused of cutting off her
husband's penis with a knife taking his
penis and throwing it into the garbage
disposal
so they're talking about that guy who
got his dick cut off his wife drugged
him tied him to a bed cut his dick off
threw it in a garbage disposal and
turned it on and it was basically
because he wanted to get a divorce from
her
police say Becker attacked him because
he filed for divorce she mutilated him
she ended the guy's [ __ ] life any
sort of quality life is over and these
women are talking about it and lo and
behold it's [ __ ] hilarious to him
they had all they could do to keep a
straight face during the first minute of
setting up the story and then all the
jokes come and they'll happen they're
[ __ ] asses off I do think it's quite
fabulous I mean
just thrown in the dogs ball it's the
funniest [ __ ] thing ever and this
right here it's because of that type of
[ __ ] that I don't feel that I am
misogynistic I just don't I think that I
am just like women I trash women the way
they trash guys it's just nobody pays
attention to the broads they don't do
you think if a guide mutilated a woman
in any shape or form
that four guys on a pregame NFL show
would be laughing about it and we'll
hear more that talk a little bit later
as well Sharon Osbourne was the guest
and she goes somebody asked do you think
the guy deserved and she goes well it
depends on what he did I think I would
just depending on why she cut it off I
mean it does depend on the reasons why
does it you know I mean that thought is
totally overlaps the thought of those
morons in the Middle East who cut
women's the lips off you know it's
[ __ ] medieval thought and it's just
considered silly I don't know what it is
I don't know but it maintains what I've
always [ __ ] said that women will do
it to you exactly what they don't want
you to do to them if you let them and I
think why so many guys are miserable in
marriages is they get married too
[ __ ] young before they really know
how to stick up for themselves in a
relationship and that's why before you
know it you're married and all your [ __ ]
is either in the basement of the garage
and she's barely touching it and and
you're wondering what the [ __ ] happened
to your life you know
I don't know the video is is gonna be up
on the mm podcast calm you know
something this is actually I like this
talking like this this is very
challenging to try and be funny with a
late night DJ voice all right this next
chunk of the podcast goes out to the
ladies ladies if you're out there and
you're single
hang in there there's a date rapist on
the horizon
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on it is Bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday I'm gonna go with April 4th I
have no [ __ ] idea what day it is
because I'm doing something unique this
week where people have asked me saying
bill you know every week you know you do
your podcast it's just you babbling
sometimes it's funny sometimes it isn't
why don't you have a [ __ ] guest on
there every once in a while how about a
comedian that people people want to know
about or already know about want to hear
his views on other [ __ ] so this week
this is a very special episode of the
Monday morning podcast well I will be
doing it with the one and only Marc
Maron Marc well thank you going on thank
you for having me bill I didn't realize
that I was actually one of the first
guests you've never had a guest I've had
Joe DeRosa who I do a I do a show with
on every once every I think leap year we
do an episode of this show uninformed we
still do it on XM it's a long [ __ ]
story but you have to have Mon because
he lives in your apartment yeah there
they go part of the contract soon his
lease that's basically yeah he lets me
crash when I come back to New York to do
to do Caroline's he sees the mixer I
feel bad I'm my guy right grab a
microphone here we go but yeah you're
the you're the first you're the first
one outside of the family you know what
you are you're Tim Roth and Reservoir
Dogs you're the only one I'm not sure I
end up with a gutshot yeah laying there
in the garage the whole [ __ ] movie
you're gonna tell me you're a cop or
something towards the end of this oh I'm
not going to tell you that no I wish I
had that biggest secret no but basically
you know what the funny thing is is uh
if the audio sounds different which
means clearer this week is um actually
this is how I have guests this is the
only way I do guests on the Monday
morning podcast is if they already have
microphones in a mixer and then I I
invited mark onto my podcast and I'm
like I got a rescue pitbull I don't want
to get sued so can half-hour into it so
I'm literally sitting in Mark's compound
out here yeah and you brought your own
equipment which I thought was very
polite eeeh but I just automatically
assume we just jump on my likes and oh
you don't think I'm a gentleman no I
brought my own mixer I brought my own
mics and then when we sit there now I'm
sitting with my little stupid [ __ ]
travel radio show and I'm like I got a
mixer
and then mark smiley well you know I
kind of got that already set up you want
to use mine all right I got the travel
bag I got the bag right there for when I
have to you know talk to people on the
road in hotel rooms and I feel awkward
look mark I'm gonna lie to you my
relationships on the rocks and I've
officially moved in you don't realize it
oh my god now I'm [ __ ] with ya I got a
car okay that's alright buddy if you can
just sleep in here and if you know how
to run a mixer you could help me out
now can I be your assistant yeah
absolutely a lot of people try to move
up in this business so I'm gonna try to
go backwards can I ask you a question
absolutely all right so I'm in I'm in
Scotland for the Glasgow Festival for
five days and I'm playing pub basements
and I did my one-man show to put in not
in a pub basement but in the pub attic
and I see posters of you yeah they're
betting the big money on bill bird I
talking to the promoter there I'm like
is he of a big draw out here she's like
I don't know we're gonna see how'd it go
I drew like 200 and then they they
papered another 400 drunk Scots oh I get
him in there at the the Kings theatre
but it went great you know hopefully you
know I'll come back again I mean I had
you feel I loved it over there I had I
actually I talked about on my podcast I
had a great time because I had a
resentment of the the Scots and of the
UK in general only because the last time
I went there had a bad experience and I
and I chose to blame them other than
myself what happened well I was sitting
I was in Edinburgh for 30 days doing
that Fringe Festival and I was literally
three months since my wife left me I was
miserable I was broken and I was on a
double bill with Kirk Fox that we were
brought out there which is the best part
of it because they paid for our lodging
and everything else usually and I'd pay
for your own [ __ ] and I couldn't give it
away I mean we were drawing audiences of
nine and you know after two weeks of
that you're like holy crap and you want
to kill yourself yeah it's like it's
like open mic every night it's like
doing a show in denim yeah it's like
it's like doing a show at a bar in
Dedham well you know what's funny dude
that's why I never did Edinboro I always
wanted to go over there but it's a
[ __ ] month
same thing with Australia there's some
sort of Australia Comedy Festival and
it's like what can I go there for ten
days and like no you got to be over here
for 30 days and it's like well you know
what well the way they were supposed to
do with my [ __ ] life back here yeah
you just you put it on hold you get
somebody to watch your dog and you hope
your girlfriend doesn't run away yeah
that's that Tiger Woods [ __ ] I was
talking about last week when I want
and his wife [ __ ] these [ __ ] women
who they they get like where they had
they marry these rich [ __ ] guy yeah
they don't have a job right and then
they have kids and they still get help
they get like a [ __ ] nanny there's
somebody clipping the hedges they don't
they don't do there's somebody clipping
the kid everything yeah so I said so
it's jokingly just [ __ ] around I'm
saying the reason why I messed around on
is because she's lazy oh yeah and it's
that's very I don't know about you
that's very unattractive quality 1sc if
you were a yeah
the same [ __ ] they don't like who knows
I mean if you want to talk about
entitlement you know I just found you
know because I've had to process this
over and over again and in terms of in
terms of what the whole spousal support
thing I mean my wife didn't you know she
wrote a book she didn't have a job or
whatever and then after it's done you
think you're equals but then they're
like you know I want support I want this
and they can exploit that that's the
saddest thing about [ __ ] divorce is
that it's set up so the woman can break
you no matter what and the reason that
was put into place might have been in
earnest I mean if you think about people
when they first put support the spousal
support I'm talking without kids not
alimony spousal support so grant that if
you're married to a woman for twenty
years and she's been doing nothing but
making you feel better for your
miserable life and then all of a sudden
it's done because he went and [ __ ]
somebody you did whatever and she's got
to enter the world again with nothing I
understand why you she owes a euro or a
little payment right to get herself
started but if you're married [ __ ]
ten minutes and the chick is perfectly
capable of doing whatever the [ __ ] she
needs to do to make a living and then
she's still busted and takes half your
shit's that [ __ ] where it's like when
it's a good one it's when there's
something good on the table they're just
as good as you and they're equals and
they want their 50% but when it's
something bad I'm just the girl I'm a
jet that's exactly and they get it
coming and going
cuz guys want to [ __ ] him okay and
that's why the judge the judge half the
time when he's judging against you is
the again he's gonna [ __ ] get some
action with your ex-wife or you if I
judge towards he throws her a little
look we had a little wink just sitting
there like I might not [ __ ] sitting
here alright so I'm married to this
woman she's a comic she's an equal he
always just a [ __ ] I was like wow you're
really gonna [ __ ] yo-yo no no I I mean
I'm not gonna do that
look I will take my son I will own mice
my [ __ ] there I had an anger problem you
know it took me a long time to learn
that you know and but I did learn it if
you're an angry
that means you're probably with somebody
married to or living with or involved in
a relationship with someone who's a pain
sponge that will deserve you know absorb
your bile and [ __ ] until they can't
take anymore then they'll want to be
wrung out by somebody else but your as
an angry guy I knew that what I learned
is that you know when you're angry you
compensate for it in other ways you know
like I used to make her breakfast
you know espresso waffles pancakes you
know one you softly weeped in the corner
that's right that's right this will back
up for what I learned you know after
after nine years there's no number of
pancakes or races shut the [ __ ] up shut
your [ __ ] mouth before we get too
deep it why don't we
what are you back up here for a second
no just because I've known you so long
there you know some of my listeners here
cross pollinate here just so they know
you know how long you been doing
stand-up or where you started out let's
let's get in okay a little stand-up
inside the Actor's Studio
I think that the first time you know I
did stand-up I was in I was in college
you know I didn't open mic I was in a
team with another guy I had met in
college guy Steve Brill when I went on
stage with with another yeah originally
we put we put I put my first stand-up
together I always wanted to do it but I
met this guy in college who we audition
for something catch a rising star at
that time it must have been 80 83 82 83
and that's the one in Cambridge and
Boston no no this was the original and
that one didn't exist then it was the
original catcher izing star that was
still up on the Upper East Side in in
New York City the original green kitchen
right okay so so they posted all these
signs around my college you know catch
rising star live on campus they were
putting together a show like a showcase
of college acts like new acts so so we
put together this team bit and we
auditioned for them you know in a room
and they liked it and then we we
auditioned for them what was what was
the name of it Marin and something I
don't remember if we had a name I think
it was just Marin and Brill and you know
as a series of sketches it wasn't even
real team it wasn't like team comedy it
wasn't like a straight guy and a goofy
guy we actually had several different
sketches that we did I kind of remember
them the one sketch was you know where
the word [ __ ] came from Jesus you came
right out of both barrels well no it was
like and I
I hate to say that word even you know
even in the context of uh you know
casual conversation even though I feel I
get in trouble for that
once when what I was trying to have a
conversation about that word with a
couple of black comics and I said the
word as I just did now and and a woman
in my audience said just the fact that
you said it I'm done with you see that's
[ __ ]
I got the word you're not supposed to
[ __ ] say it's just how like you can't
even like that that's when you're people
who do stuff like that it's like they're
not even listening to you they just have
lists of words like these words are good
why these words are bad that there's no
like right but I can't negate a feeling
that she had I mean you know if that
word no matter what context it is makes
her compendious ly upset then there's
nothing I can do about that whether it's
right or wrong I you know I can't
account for her feelings so we did that
sketch which was these two these two
guys they were like you know white guys
who were working and they were trying to
name the you know they figure out a
nickname for the people and it was like
diggers and it was stupid
right and then we did another one we did
that Neil Armstrong if Neil Armstrong
were on the moon the first moonwalk if
you were on acid so my buddy played
ground control and I played I was doing
the bit where I was on the memo stand
crushed
yeah I would did well and then we did
another one a Japs funeral like we did
these two Jewish girls who were at if
you're over a friend you know and
they're like oh my god she looks so thin
you know that kind of [ __ ] there you go
you kind of got everybody yeah yeah we
knew axe Jews so what happens then is
that we you know they we we audition at
the comedy connection we go to do it
live we've done it in a room they said
we want to see you live and we bond bond
it's just like a sucking silence now
what do you think so the wait a minute
wave so the first time you ever did it
on comedy stage now I've always said the
first time if I bomb the first time I
don't know if I would ever have the
courage to go back and do it again well
well that would that's the difference
between people that are hooked on it and
people yet people who are born comics
and people who are just you know
dabbling is that like really if you
bombed
you would have done it again it would
have taken me a minute had it been like
theme just a sheer [ __ ] embarrassment
of okay well I mean you can still deal
with stand-up is you can still eat it
today I'm 18 years old I can
but this is the thing you have years of
good shows to be like well you know I
know I don't suck at this I had a bad
night but you know it right out of the
gate oh yeah
the bad night thing is hard to really
get around your head because still hurts
me if I bomb but when you're up there
and you know you know this whole idea
that you know it's it's never the
audience is [ __ ]
I mean sometimes you're on the audience
right and you know like you you can tell
you know you've done your [ __ ] and you
can see where they're peaking laughter
wise and you know after a certain point
that you're they're not gonna go any
further than that
so I'll get after I'm just gonna have to
realize this is the best I'm gonna do in
this situation and either eat it you
don't take the head or or make light of
the fact yeah I've learned like there's
nothing worse than being angry on stage
but I hurts I actually heard a funny
story last night I was doing a gig and
this this Booker Jeff Wills from the
yeah he was telling a story he saw one
night uh said Bill Hicks did an entire
show with his back to the audience it
was like a bachelorette party there was
every [ __ ] thing you do yeah those
like you know those Booker's they love
to talk about those stories you know but
if anyone else did that now they would
never [ __ ] work in that club again
all these guys pretend like you know
like up Bill Hicks was the guy and he
went on stage and angrily tanked in a
brilliant inspired way right most all
the time but if someone existed like
that now he wouldn't have a [ __ ] shot
do you think so absolutely well I bet I
bet he was still selling tickets at that
point I did you you can't you can't you
can't turn your back on a [ __ ] crowd
and ever think that you're gonna work I
don't think that's true I think that the
reason he got booked in this country
primarily was to to make club owners
feel like they were you know they were
at least championing something terrific
like I think they innately knew this guy
was special there was no one like him
and even the fact that he didn't sell
tickets or alienated the audience every
time they were gonna have him twice a
year to keep their conscience straight
all so they could be dicks to everybody
else basically kinda but just did sort
of like to at least support that least
they knew well enough that he was an
inspired guy but I've gotten angry
onstage I did it the other night dude
not in it and it would been a long time
because I used to snap all the time
doesn't say that's kind of an
understatement
coming from you yeah but that's like me
saying I've snapped nobody but you know
I'm pretty accessible now no no yeah
your way your way
but I happen at the store dude it
happened at this ie how long ago two
nights ago and I I I could do this whole
thing yeah much better now much better
now bye snap one time was it about 48
hours ago I couldn't believe I did it
was such a different person you know
that place brings it out of it come on
The Comedy Store brings it out of you
sometimes that's what I love it though
me too it's so [ __ ] so I'm on stage
it is evil it is it's just pay the beads
on on hate you know you feel the walls
wanting you to lose it you know it's
just in the place yeah so I'm onstage is
like 40 people in the room and like I'm
already like you just right when I get
in there you have some kid that kid
David Taylor you know that kid he's a
dog I used to do comedy he's very
cynical and negative and I just I wasn't
in the mood for it hadn't seen him in
months and I said hi to him he goes I'm
staying around just to see you you
better be good and so right away I'm
like I haven't seen you in the [ __ ]
long time you have no right to [ __ ]
talk like that to me enough with the
negative [ __ ] yeah you know what I
bought a storm dog getting angry again
marangu fur and I walk back you make me
feel really good about myself because
usually I sound like the angry psycho I
can be like the happy person yeah take a
break yeah there you go go ahead you go
alright so I get honest and it's magical
went on who I think is just terrific I
love how oh yeah I think he's [ __ ]
hilarious totally original unique
stylist real storyteller he does good
you know and then he brings me up and
they're you know I'm getting laughs
there's only like 30 or 40 people in the
loire and it's going fine there's an old
couple up front there maybe in their mid
50s early 60s and they someone talked to
him and they asked him about religion I
think Neal Brennan did they said they
were Jews I'm like fine so I'm doing my
show and they're not laughing at nothing
and I looked at them and I said I'm
sorry my two filthy want me to talk some
political stuff you know is that what it
is and then the old man looks at me and
goes you're not funny yeah and I and I
just had this moment where I'm like all
right dude all right and I said you know
what I am funny I know I'm funny I'm
doing well with the rest of the audience
all right and and I and I understand
what you're saying and and then like for
some reason I just looked at him I said
but the fact that that's what you had to
pull out of your guts to say to me in
this situation makes me [ __ ] hate you
and there's a real punch line there now
you lose the rest of the crowd that's
right this is quite an aluminum like
what that wasn't funny what did I say
did not come out funny now you turn on
the rest of them okay then I turn on the
rest of them and then and then he goes
you know you asked and I said we did you
could have qualified it like how about
you're not funny to me all of a sudden
you're the god of this [ __ ] room
you're the Almighty you're the one that
has the last word [ __ ] that right so
that and then like how you in a bad mood
before you got there because you're a
little because I gotta say the read of
this guy saying you're not funny sounds
to me like you said some [ __ ] that he
didn't want to hear it was more of a
subject thing not nothing no I just it
was a general thing so then the rest of
the act I'm doing my act and everyone's
laughing every time everyone else
laughed I looked at him and I went huh
huh and then like you know at the end of
my set and bringing up Brent is easy and
he stands up with his wife and they walk
out and while I'm still on stage
bringing up Stephen like a very powerful
statement very powerful I'll see you
later dad ah Jesus mark cuz that's what
I said to him I said hey you know it's
like every [ __ ] Jewish guy that has
that kind of judgment that's your rage
is just some surrogate for my father and
I understand I'm translating I'm
transposing some contempt on you but you
could have [ __ ] chose a different way
alright alright anyways Marc Maron here
on Monday morning part that's not funny
no no no no no I'm just letting people
know I'm acting you know what I just did
there acted like this was a live show I
like it like we'll take some calls like
when it takes we're actually doing this
on Easter Sunday and I Mark asked me
what I want to do I said I would do it
Sunday Nico you do realize it's Easter
and I was like yeah I'm really not into
that [ __ ] but I actually went to church
this morning with my with my girlfriend
and her mom because her mom goes so I
went with her and dude you should have
heard the homily yeah the guy was up
there the homilies basically after they
tell one of those Jewish right yeah yeah
so after they tell like the little Jesus
did he yeah they if I can opener yeah
tells a couple of little ones then the
pre springs at home yes I'll dressed up
the headliner Catholic looking oh yeah
oh yeah it's the whole thing oh yeah
definitely it's looking confused outside
yeah how is anyone any adhere to that
religion after this is you can't you
can't I even till I even was talking to
something some older people they were
saying the same thing like when the
collection thing went around
I wanted to give money for the [ __ ]
car wash or whatever but I'm thinking
like yeah but isn't this gonna go
towards a defense attorney for somebody
who did all the [ __ ] deaf kid I'm not
giving you any more money
sort that out first that's right at me
and now it's like it's not an American
thing it's also in Europe and it's and
the numbers and this has been going on
for generations it's almost like it was
a contest with these guys it's like does
it count if you same kids like yeah
women do you want to be a cardinal
you got a diddle at least [ __ ] three
I have a theory about it I think I know
why there are so many gay or pedophile
priests because I think that these
communities going back you know hundreds
of years certainly in this country and I
imagine in other countries that when a
mother or a community saw that one of
their male kids was going the way of the
the [ __ ] you know they started to pick
up that they were effeminate I mean
communities are yeah that's a gay thing
just no no no let me go this way I know
no what I'm saying is that when they saw
that happening they muscled these kids
into the priesthood they said that as
opposed to live a life of sin as a
homosexual probably go that way let's
push them towards the priesthood
now the and I'm not saying this will
offset the dick-sucking that's right and
I think what happens is they but they
couldn't do that in the priesthood so I
think a lot of them you know I'm not
saying that they're homosexuals I know
that they're pedophiles but I think that
the guilt compounded with the idea that
they may have been homosexual and then
that actually made them more evil
because then they would prey upon these
kids that couldn't say anything that you
know they could terrify and completely
control with this horrendous urge they
have I gotta be honest with you I have
no idea because it fascinates me cuz
like I think there's a lot of people out
there they confuse being gay with being
a pedophile because it is a guy and a
boy you know what I mean so that's
completely different because it's like
all right you know you could stick me
and in that place and say that I can't
hook up with anybody
yeah and I'm still not going to [ __ ] a
little girl you know what I mean I had a
files but I think that that's absolutely
true but I'm saying that I bet you a lot
of them we're probably on the on the on
the on the train if they weren't abused
by priests themselves you're on the
train well that's the thing about those
guys is what they've sixteen thousand
it's like not on
you ruined you ruin someone's life the
second you do that that childhood is
[ __ ] over you ruin them you blow a
hole in their soul it's over and then
this is the thing and then they go on to
have kids and even if they even if they
don't do anything to them it's just it
detach them you generations you're
talking 16,000 people like that old
pearl commercial they have five kids
they have five kids they they're all
affected by that oh absolutely
and I know what that they're all
troubled and lost so there are more
candidates for the for the church
yeah they more as they become comedians
that's right they're actually creating
new lost people in hopes that they will
come back to the Catholic Church yeah so
I think this this priest because of the
mandate above all of that [ __ ] was kind
of open this week this priest I guess
this guy's kind of like he's like that
the instead of the Comics comic this
guy's like the priests priests like in
the back of the room yeah the Deacons in
the back that's great
this guy's great nobody he he like he's
actually admitted that he actually
thought about leaving the priesthood for
a while he's actually not he didn't say
why but today during his homily when
he's surmising the Jesus story he said
something he goes you know a lot of
people look at this religion you know
look at our religion like we do we say
the the wafer is the body of Christ and
the wine is his blood and they think
that's nonsense a lot of people think
that because we think that Jesus dwells
in all of us that that's nonsense he
kept going kept talking about major
cornerstones in a religion and people
thinking was nonsense and I was sitting
there going oh my god this is like the
[ __ ] Domino's Pizza moment where they
finally admit that their pizza sucks
remember that yeah like dude what
happened [ __ ] up we're not recording
no we are recording but I think okay
we're okay we're okay we're okay yeah
there was a little jump there I
apologize I think we're okay I thought I
had to measure completely freak Tommy we
just actually literally for the first
time in the two and a half years of the
Monday morning podcast it came it's
stopped
it never stops don't lie it's a live
goddamn sure I just want to make sure
that wasn't it oh yeah he thought he
thought the metronome was on that would
be bad my bad my bad
all right so yeah so he was busy Christ
and he's sitting there he's having like
the Domino's Pizza mom you know where
they admit that that pizza sucked after
all these years yeah and then they still
try to put out a [ __ ]
in large pizza for five bucks what do
you think it's going to taste like you
idiot
but he somehow spun it around where it
was it was a closed you know what he's
doing he's actually telling the truth
the way he can tell the truth
without having it be a national scandal
just going I can't explain the way did
the guy he's [ __ ] good I got a minute
I got admitted Dave Attell was a priest
yeah yeah yeah he got you I was like
this guy this guy is good look and I got
into it this week with like I used to do
this this this section on the podcast
called og and I would talk about a
religion and you know for the most part
you know I was saying that they they I
can't even get into it but every once in
a while people listen to the old podcast
where I was kind of trashed and
organized religion and and they come at
me and they drive me [ __ ] nuts
because they just make grand statements
like you're like yeah I said you know I
went to like I went to church for the
first time in 15 years like a month like
two months ago right and when I went I
was like I didn't like what they were
saying but there was a feeling I had I
like the sense of community and then
what they do is they go you that feeling
you were feeling how was Jesus yeah yeah
they always they date like they own that
[ __ ] feeling so then I'm sitting
there going like talking about their
[ __ ] stories that don't even make
sense
Adam and Eve forget about how you know
their kids would then have to [ __ ] and
then we'd be all descendents of [ __ ]
children right they they don't even
address the dinosaurs I'm like what
about the dinosaurs and all that never
address that they always just they never
learn the e-mails back and forth they
will never address the [ __ ] point you
make they just spin it all off into
others it's okay Jesus is waiting for
you and all this type of [ __ ] and it
just it drives me [ __ ] nuts like and
then I I show them where science like
this is what I can't stand that they'll
attack scientist and say what they're
saying is wrong until they can't [ __ ]
deny it anymore like the fact that the
Sun doesn't go around the earth and
after they've tortured and killed
[ __ ] people then what they do is then
they embrace it and then they act like
it's theirs and they're like well who
made the scientist geez has made the
scientist and it's like it's just a spin
thing and they just hold on to their
beliefs until it becomes irrefutable and
then they say it sort of like those
people like well how I am now what I we
thought was fascinating is that these
cults remember years ago there was more
of them where you'd have this cult where
the leader would say the world is going
to end on
this date tomorrow tomorrow's the day
yeah and they get these these followers
frothing that and like ready prepared
they're underground they're in Bunker's
they're gonna go they're all strapped in
and then the day comes and it passes and
it doesn't happen I would love to be at
that sermon yeah because then it's sort
of like well you know it doesn't mean
it's not gonna happen and now that we've
got all this underground infrastructure
trust in us that's right test enough
let's start a mushroom farm let's use
this yeah now that we're in the basement
I just don't understand how they read me
up revive tell you why because you got
people are so [ __ ] stupid they're
stupid after that debt that you yeah you
got it you're seeing that now even
outside the religion even in politics
that because there's so much information
out there people here's what here's what
really fascinates me is they will
believe what they believe and you can't
shake their beliefs even with facts
because now because there's so much
information because the Internet
they can just go well that's your
version that's that's the spin the truth
yeah the facts are the spin and that
they you know that you can believe that
but you're wrong
now dude it drives me it drives me nuts
in it and then they'll just like at one
point I uncle Nucky
like you guys have persecuted science
like basically my theory is that science
is religion for intelligent people
forward-thinking people and religion is
science for morons
because whatever they can't explain they
just invent [ __ ] bushes talking to
people sharing albatrosses or whatever
the [ __ ] they have conspiracy theory say
more and this is what they ended up
saying she ends up writing back well
actually science has proven the Bible
correct over and over again so I'm like
okay what's the where's the follow-up
statement to support that nothing yeah
there's nothing yeah there's nothing
there's no follow-up statement
whatsoever all they do is they just they
like I can actually sit here and prove
to you that the [ __ ] earth goes
around the Sun because of scientists I'm
too [ __ ] stupid to prove it but it
actually on paper makes sense none of
this [ __ ] can be proven on paper and and
then when you show stuff that can be
proven on paper that disproves their
[ __ ] then they do that [ __ ] well well
God created the scientist he created the
paper that they wrote in it like yeah
they just sort of circus I actually find
I tapped out in that moment I was like
you know I get it now you yo no matter
what I say are gonna believe what you're
gonna say and I'm never going to
Vince you that's right of the way that I
think so [ __ ] it so I'm done with it
but we always the funny thing unbeliev
yeah you can't you can't go to it
there's no reason to go to war with
those people because belief is
impenetrable no matter how delusional
they are it's based in complete
ignorance and it's something it's
something outside of of intelligence
yeah but this is what I don't care cuz I
bought into it when I was a kid we were
scared and I was I was listening to was
scared and then also thinking like
alright and some of this is good it was
like my [ __ ] houses like my life some
of it was good someone was bad but then
it just got to a point where it's like
this [ __ ] doesn't make sense and it's so
loud in your head you can't ignore it
and I don't understand I that's a real
[ __ ] arrogant statement I'm gonna say
only yeah you gotta be a [ __ ] to just
continue to to block it out
well that's the difference between free
thinking and and thinking based and fear
you know cuz like the way it works in my
mind is oh well if the world is a scary
place everything is is serendipitous who
the hell knows when you're gonna get hit
by a truck who knows when the earth is
gonna fall into the sea or start shaking
no one knows anything there's very
little there's very few things we have
control over in our life it just is I
mean you know how this this garage could
slide down the hill at any set who the
hell knows very few things out of our
are in our control almost nothing right
now depending on how frightening that is
even if you understand everything in in
you know proportionately like you know
the the possibility of this happening
versus that having even if you're
scientific about that how how much fate
has to do with our everyday life that is
not completely comforting so depending
on how overwhelmed ooh you are right oh
yeah so I believe on some level the need
to believe or feel like you're part of
something bigger than you to sort of
justify your existence or make you feel
comfortable in the world it's probably
almost genetic I just feel that that the
way communities function or whatever but
you know you can make it your community
you can make it your television you can
make it sports whatever the hell it is
there's part of our brain that wants to
be part of a bigger thing in order to
feel that we're significant thank you
just go in the ground and I'm
comfortable right but I'm just talking
the need to believe now you're being
able to grow unbelievable potatoes
that's fine with my Irish DNA in the
soil but I think that the people that
whose lives are so [ __ ] miserable
that they can't even fathom owes to us
happy-go-lucky sunzha but we got a lot
to be grateful for we do doesn't mean we
appreciate it that's true that's true
but but but there I think there's some
people that can't handle it and and the
idea of heaven to them which is I agree
with you is ridiculous and and frankly
boring I I mean the idea that we live
forever I can barely get through this
one right and in the end the idea of
that and the idea that you like it's
going to be better because [ __ ]
boredom oh my god doesn't make sense
like if it's absolute [ __ ] euphoria
forever it would get boring oh my god
it would be that boring and that's like
at some point you do I can I get a day
pass to hell I want to plan a good time
maybe he'll be like Vegas in heaven
Tijuana are you going I'm going to hell
for three weeks I got some time off from
this tedious [ __ ] happy [ __ ] yeah
I want to be able to feel happiness
again like me on fire for [ __ ] three
weeks so I can appreciate you gotta go
have you been to the fifth ring that's
awesome
awesome yeah yeah we went there with the
wife and I went yeah it was tremendous
they had great performers you know all
the comics went to hell so they're all
there you got to go to the fifth ring
it's tremendous great shows great really
the hex
not even the hacks the--who Dini there
it's amazing
who's speaking of that [ __ ] you know I
did a like I did a theatre was it the
San Jose improv recently and he
allegedly performed there and all these
guys was fine was a classic old theatre
yeah that it had had gone through that
hundred year of history of like the most
beautiful thing ever and people flocked
right in an opulent place and yeah
slowly deteriorated to like a porn porno
movie Michael jerking off and right
somebody like Jackie when asked us to
put some money together and they [ __ ]
revived it got a colorful history of
corruption and filth oh yeah great
absolutely absolutely it's like show
business should yeah so I went to I did
the the Gibson Amphitheatre last night
for that Kevin and bean show radio
showing of this cancer but I remember
when the beam was in what was the name
of the comedy team Stephen beam that
proceeded Zito and beam from Boston is
that
yeah [ __ ] you no I didn't know that yeah
crispy no I always heard about her yeah
those guys used to kill that's that
that's them okay you what would you what
would you what would you why would you
why would you days to open with I'm a
Jew Dennehy's a [ __ ] uh yeah that was the
aim yeah that was a [ __ ] 80s man that
was before when did you start well
getting back to me after I did the team
thing I was more thinking how she WAPA
dude WAPA do would actually get a laugh
well no no I may in order to think that
[ __ ] we were talking about the update
other night we were looking at a
particular comedian going you know if
this is the [ __ ] 80s this guy would
be famous by now cuz they just seemed
everybody back then it's completely
subjective if you have like if you had
any sort of a character the glasses
you're wearing if you always wore those
on stage if you did that then three
evening at The Improv the guy with the
glasses yeah but you can't even get a
pair of glasses it doesn't look like
this no believe me I don't want to
surrender to the horn rims but you
really you really have to struggle and
fight to find something different right
now the Buddy Holly's there they're
everywhere I mean some version of them I
used to wear round glasses remember and
and I can't find money about you yeah
you got that whole Rockstar look so when
you wore the round ones you had the John
Lennon look and now you're looking a
little Buddy Holly and the crickets
that's alright I'd rather be a Peggy
shoe then then no that's not true
they're both good I'm not gonna take
anything away from John Lennon but at
the speaking of the 80s just quickly
because I feel like I left it hanging is
that after I did the team thing you know
he graduated and went on to direct Adam
Sandler movies I wrote a whatever Steve
Brill did but I stayed in Boston and I
started on my own I started played
against Sam's in the basement doing open
mics with Kenny Rogers and everybody
else my last year of college I was doing
open mics that summer and I drank myself
almost to death and was waiting you know
how long have those stories when you
bring up Kenny yeah well I I mean we're
not with him but I used to just wait you
had back then you had a wait to go on
though everyone else was done for three
people I couldn't take it and then when
I graduated college I moved to Hollywood
I became a doorman at the Comedy Store I
was there for a year and then I hit the
wall on drugs and I went back to boss
and started over to catch up wait a
minute slow down here let's do this
through the behind the music here Marc
Maron a lot of people know the story
already no you don't put it out there
again oh no I don't care but I'm
now people who know me know it why I
came out to after I graduated college I
already had a pretty good coke monkey on
my back so I drove out here I moved in I
was in Culver City
living with Steve just out of curiosity
ad campaign cocaine the big lie of
course I started I started when the ad
campaign was coke it's good for you yeah
yeah it was no more addictive than a
caffeine good times we were all doing it
so I come out here and I move into a
place in Culver City with Steve Brill
that guy we wrote a screenplay and that
I never wanted to talk to him again
because it was unbearable
and then I auditioned at the store to
you know to see if I could start doing
comedy and Mitzi said you're funny
you can be a doorman so so I immediately
moved into crest Hill and I was a
doorman in 1987
you know when Penniston was was just
starting to come to break and I met you
suck well I met Carl and Carl was Sam's
best friend and he Carly oh yeah he gave
me a watch and said you're good people
when sam comes back I want you to meet
him and you don't know this story
no I'll tell it to you so it's live
through it I can tell you second
television no no I'm not having done it
that much and certainly people on your
podcast might not know it the people
that don't listen to both of our yeah
but they know if they know Sam Kinison
where's my favorites this is a self
[ __ ] moment I want to I'll tell you
it's a great story all right so like I
you know I didn't really know that much
about Kennison when I got there I'd seen
him once or twice but I really dismissed
him as this new novelty act you know
this screaming guy and I I wasn't here
nor there with him
so when Carl said me introduce you to
Sam I didn't know what that meant
so Sam comes and you know and cartina
Carl's like there's that guys talking
he's talking about he's the new head
doorman and sam was a guy the doorman so
you're the new guy you know am I guess I
was hang out and talk and I'm like all
right so so I'm living in crest Hill so
he knows that place too right so the
first night I ever hang out Sam Kinison
you know he comes up to Crystal which is
that house mid-to used to own and I'm
staying there you know I used to live
there a lot of P so that yeah that's
that classic house just a lot of
listeners know when comics like you
would move out to LA if mitzi tapped you
on the shoulder and knighted you you
then moved into this house right where
you had to pay rent and also drive the
[ __ ] Jeep and take Neil get her chick
oh yeah totally totally but like the
amount of comedians who live there yeah
dice were there the Todd was there
Tamayo this was a tricky thing Tamayo to
key who used to date Sam was a Japanese
comic I don't know what happened to her
but she lived upstairs you know I lived
in dices old room Todd wasn't moved in
yet I'm trying to think
Todd lemma she he later went on to have
he's called self thought Todd and he
eventually had some sort of aneurysm and
showed up at the club saying he'll years
after Sam died saying Sam's coming and
you know he was sent to Florida but but
it's that's a Schubert lived there for a
while that place is evil yeah oh
definitely definitely
so so what happens is I'm living up
there and and Sam says you know let's go
up to the house you know and this is the
way it worked back then is Monday night
in the late 80s was no cover night and
all the rooms were free so all the
freaks from Hollywood and everywhere
came to the store on Monday night and
that was Sam's night he would show up at
about 11:30 12:00 o'clock on Monday
take over the stage in the main room
which was just filled with rock and roll
drug freaks and just say no this is like
hair metal hair metal dog all different
kinds yeah hair metal the end of towards
the end of hair metal yeah so like you
know the people that would come to the
club it was pretty spectacular you know
and I was a doorman and at that time
that people you'd see on stage were
people like dice Damon Wayans Kennison
Pryor was still coming by occasionally
Christ you know so I was just I just
entered this world right so Sam says
let's hang out so we go up to the house
it's just me and Sam was doing coke he
pulls out all this coke and we're just
sitting there and he's like so you're
the new guy you know he's looking right
in my face right look me in the eyes
Mayer and I like a man who can look me
in the eyes and like holy [ __ ] all right
I'm looking right so we're sitting there
doing coke and I thought I was mr.
rock-and-roll I can handle coke so I'm
doing coke with Sam and he's laying out
the the world you know I'd Sam you know
Dee's doing the thing I cannot tell you
how it works here you know and then like
you know out of nowhere he goes hey
Marion you know you ever burn money and
I'm like no and he's like let's burn
some money so Sam pulls out these $100
bills and we start burning money at
Sam's I'm figuring [ __ ] idea okay let's
burn some money so we're sitting there
burning money and we're getting [ __ ]
up and it's about 3:30 4:00 in the
morning and we're at a coke and Sam's
wasted and I'm kind of wasting a lot of
money too
now he
shouldn't have done that to me cuz I
called that back later and he wasn't
that happy about it I mean I made him do
it like the way this I'll tell you what
happens is the first night so he's like
we're out of Coco's go get some more
coke and I'm like all right I don't I
don't know where we're going so we get
in my car I'm driving like pretty much
one of the biggest stars in comedy
through the Hollywood Hills at like 3:30
in the [ __ ] morning he's half passed
out in my car like and I'm trying like
where we going where we going he like
he's like wakes up he goes I don't even
know you you could kill me and I'm like
where we go and dude so we end up with
this guy's house now at this point is he
stopped being Sam Kinison and it's
become some annoying guy that you're
partying with no yes still he was really
good staying in sin still Sam okay even
when he was like sloppy you know right
when it got pathetic he still held on to
that thing and it was always sort of men
never burned money dude I I started too
[ __ ] late in this business I so so
the fun was gone so we get to this guy's
house this guy who as time went on I
really know was a hairdresser by day but
with Sam's coke dealer at the time and
it's out on its side that was down on
Crescent Heights wasn't that far from
the store so we knock on this door this
guy shows up at the door in his bathrobe
clearly woke him up from sleeping I gots
and there's we need some coke and we
barrel into this guy's house and we're
in this guy's bedroom and Sam just sits
on the floor it crashes on the for you
those got kneed you got any booze and
and this guy was like I just got these
miniatures I got in the plane so now Sam
is sitting there with these like
Smirnoff bottles of vodka drinking the
Smirnoff you look like a giant like he
should have been surrounded by little
rock and roll people going and then like
you know he passes out on this guy's
floor and you know the guy gives me the
coke you know I end up paying for it and
then I go out through an Asian guy
throwing fire fireworks no no no it
should have been so I'm like oh I don't
know what the hell tell you I'm gonna
take off I guess you'll deal with him
he's like you're not [ __ ] leaving him
here I don't want him to pull a Belushi
on me and I'm like what and my god [ __ ]
so now I got him like you know get him
up and walk him out and throw him in the
car and he was big and I get him back to
the house we go in he doesn't even do
the coke he ends up crawling on the
floor in the living room just laying on
the floor and passing out which is
something he did a lot because that
house became the party house was he
draped in the scarves and twelve [ __ ]
head wraps not yet and I mean this is
early Sam so it was too
just a trenchcoat in the cap dude this
is not this is pretty rock and roll Sam
I don't have any story that can match
this I'm this point that the falling out
was was the better story I mean cuz like
that year well how does that night end
he just passes out he passes out and
then you know he wakes up and then you
know we build this bond I get sucked
into the Kennison entourage and I'm now
like you know doing my graduate work and
cutting coke for Sam Kinison and and it
was my job at that point to organize the
party like Sam would do this every
Monday night it became very taxing
because I knew he was coming and what
would happen is he'd show up in the
[ __ ] party would start and like you'd
show up at the store he'd give me a
couple hundred bucks and I'd go buy all
the booze and cigarettes and mixers that
everyone needed to bring up to the house
so I would get in this pattern after a
while I knew how long the party could go
on for it could go on for two or three
days see 15 years I had no idea you did
this stuff yeah so like so I used to get
this [ __ ] so I go buy all this booze but
I know what would happen is that he'd
show up with 20 people and then come day
two or three it'd just be me and Sam and
some freaks like you know they you know
it'd end up like eight people so I would
hide liquor all around the house now you
up for the three days yeah how the [ __ ]
did you write any jokes well I was only
working the belly room and you know we
were all in the in we're almonds cut in
the Comedy Store at school in the same
school which is like you know you lived
your life as hard as possible and you
got up there and he [ __ ] did the work
well there's other newer comedians
resent you that you you got into the Sam
know because like at that time you know
it was like who the [ __ ] would want to
be in that entourage I mean at that time
you know the guy used to be Mitzi's
assistant was like you know he used to
call us a Manson family because you know
Sam was like this weird charismatic
freak that dwelled in the underworld and
most of the comics there were you know
we're sort of like you know just working
comics I mean he was one of a kind
that's what always blew my mind if I
could just stop this for just half a
second was where did guys like Seinfeld
fit in cuz he was around during that
time like I just can't imagine like that
universe where there was like that is
that level of party anybody he would
just come in but he was singular in that
you know he you know he was he
celebrated it I mean there's a lot of
comets as you know and as we all know
that had their abuse and substance of
problems but you know they were trying
to hide it and just do their job there
were plenty of hacky
except were [ __ ] up on drugs but the
fact that Sam had to live the life as
the Beast
like of the beast he had to honor it so
he was the first one that was shameless
about it and then you'd see all these
other comics that you I don't need to
drop names or mention names where they'd
come around and you know they'd hang out
and do some blow but they wouldn't want
to be tagged with it you know there was
a lot of guys that would hang out and do
coke and be like you know don't tell
nobody you know I mean I saw a lot of
that I mean there are certain people
that would come up and party with us
that we weren't allowed to do drugs like
one time Ted Nugent was hanging around
and Sam was like no drugs because Ted's
clean so we had to sit there and I'll
behave ourselves for the three hours at
Nugent sat there and thought old wild
boar stories right well he used to hold
court at this house so I'd go out and
stock up the place and set up the party
and then he'd come up with all his
freaks and then it just a lot of times
would end up just me and him or two or
three people and eventually I started to
lose my mind
and I wasn't progressing as a comic I
was losing a lot of weight I was
sleep-deprived I was driving poor
[ __ ] to the airport and Mitzi's when
they had to go play the dunes cuz that
was part of my my job to work at the
store was to drive the guys to the
airport I remember one time I was
driving Mendoza and campanero to the to
the Burbank Airport because they had to
go play the comedy store that was at the
dunes at that time and I've been up all
night and there was no gas and I could
have killed those [ __ ] guys Christ so
like so what ultimately started to
happen I started to lose my mind you
know you get to sleep deprived too much
drugs he starts hearing voices in your
head like you know and you're a
conspiracy guy I had a mystical
conspiracy organized around Sam and
Hollywood and how I you know like I used
to do this bit about how like you know I
thought I was special I didn't think it
was a sickness because you know when you
hear voices in your head it's never one
it's always many and you spend a lot of
time trying to get them to pick a
[ __ ] leader you have someone's got
something to say he step to the front of
the head I need instructions so I'm
losing my mind and and thank [ __ ] god
you know it [ __ ] hit the fan ultimately
after almost a year of this living like
this
you know you know Sam had you know he
you know when every week for a year you
were up for three days straight yeah and
told me once I got out unless I went out
now to threw near two days but you'd
have to take breaks I mean it wasn't
he'd go on the road I mean wasn't that
steady but you know it was part of a
cycle because even when he was gone we
were all hopped up
and like he'd do weird [ __ ] you know I
mean there one time you know there's
this chick I remember one night at the
table there was some girl like sitting
at the table you never knew who showed
up there I started to get that creepy
feeling like someone's gonna die it
might be me
because there's too much weirdness going
on up there and I remember one night
like some chick was at the table and she
had a bandaged wrist you know and I know
when she's all wasted and like you know
so I said why is your wrist bandage and
she goes I tried to kill myself and I
said well why don't you do the other
wrist and she does because I didn't want
to [ __ ] up my watch and I'm like boy you
know and then she she goes I just
remember so like she goes into the other
room and passes out in a couple hours
later Sparkie comes out to me goes I
think Sam pissed on that girl and I'm
like what are you talking about and like
she was laying in Todd's bed it was piss
all over the place and Sam had this
weird thing where occasionally he'd piss
on things it was just he was weird
so generally killing my Sam Kinison
right go ahead
well here's but here's the story though
like I didn't know he did the drugs I
just don't need to know the peeing well
this is that this is the punchline this
story now I apologize if people have
heard this story but it is sort of
comedy lore that you know it'll interest
you okay these be this guy that hung
around the Comedy Store he was a
Satanist his name was Dave London and
III should fictionalize his name his
name was Dave I don't know whatever
that's - what so this guy had like a
pentagram
oh my god you said his whole name and
then he goes I'm gonna fictionalize it
you just said just his real first yeah
yeah yeah I'm just trying to help out I
don't want to hurt anyone's feelings or
get myself in trouble so this guy had a
pentagram tattooed on his heart he had
666 on his arm he had the mark of the
Illuminati and the other arm he looked
like Christopher Walken he was a dope
fiend he needs to hang around the store
and we couldn't get rid of him you know
the store is it attracts these [ __ ]
people and they're they're there because
there's no it's just that open hallway
where people itself selections it's a
psychic drain for [ __ ] dark weird
people you know it's a home they it's
for the for the the people who don't fit
in fit in at the store you know which is
why I love it so much but this guy used
to hang around and Sam hated him I don't
I never knew really why so one night you
know a a couple of nights I can't
remember if it was a couple days before
his HBO special premiered he brought all
his guitars and [ __ ] he played guitar up
to the house we had this big jam session
out on the patio it was gray Sam brought
him up yes Saint Sam Sam Sam just set up
the story and you know he took off and
I'd put all the good equipment in my
bedroom because Sam did want to take it
home so a couple nights after that we
have a party at the house you know Sam's
up there and this guy said Dave the
Satanist shows up and we're all doing
drugs and it's getting weird and they're
sitting at the table and everybody's
holding court Sam isn't in Dave's there
and a few other people and and Dave the
Satanist says you know like they're
getting into it about Satanism like you
know it's like the Beast versus the mini
beast it was ridiculous and then Dave
goes I'm gonna tell aunt Ellen lavay
about you you're not a real Satanist and
Sam just like stands up and this was a
common tactic he used in fighting he
stands up he throws a drink in this
guy's face and pops him oh that's good
it's like the old throw salt in the
Galvez it's sand yeah and there's a
fight there's a scuffle and then you
know and then I'm like yeah I break it
up and Dave's all [ __ ] up and all the
other people in the room were freaked
out and Dave the Satanist his shirts all
ripped up and I'm like you gotta get out
of here man you just got to get out of
here you got to get out of his face he's
like I'm not [ __ ] leavin [ __ ] that I'm
like well I gotta leave cuz I gotta pick
up a buddy of mine at the airport I
don't know what the hell they're doing
yet so i lock him in my room all right I
locked him in my room with the guitars
that sounded like a good idea to me
right so I have to leave cuz my buddy's
flying in and I told him I've been
hanging out with Sam and this and you're
high right now of course I was high so I
got to go pick my buddy up at the
airport and I'd been telling him all
about Sam you know and this guy lives in
Boston and he's like I used to do coke
with him too and he was excited to come
out so I pick him up at the airport we
go to his hotel and I'm like I want to
stay out there I don't go back tonight
I'm gonna crash at the hotel so I crash
at the hotel all right and then we drive
back to the house you know me and my
buddy in the morning all right and we
walk in and it's like you know I walk
into my room and it's been you know it
the door had been kicked in the bed's
all [ __ ] up all the equipment's gone
I'm like [ __ ] would happen now walk into
the living room and there's Sam sitting
with two or three other people a weird
mix of people and they've been at it all
night you know and I walk in and I'm
with my friend and I'm like this is my
buddy bill and Sam just sitting there he
goes Marren I pissed on your bed you
want to know why
and I go yeah I do want to know why Sam
because cuz you let that idiot sleep
with my guitars and I know then
apparently I turn to my friend Bill and
I said I told you I knew him that was
the last time I ever slept in that bed
9:00 then that was did the guy [ __ ] up
his guitars and everything like that no
you do anything Sam just had his [ __ ]
freak out you know it's manic psychotic
cocaine freaka I don't know what the
hell transpired but I never signed know
him I never slept in that bed again and
a couple days later I snapped at the
store and lost my [ __ ] and I packed up
everything I went up to the coke dealer
who was not the hairdresser at this
point it was this Palestinian dude who
was kind of scary I said I don't get it
man I'm kicked out of the group man what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do and the coke
dealer said you gotta get out of here
man you gotta start your own thing and
when the drug dealers telling you to
leave yeah you got it whoo yeah so I
pack up my car I gave away everything I
don't find Jesus son back up my car and
I think I'm hearing voices and I'm you
know and I and I leave I leave I call my
brother in Tucson I said I'm [ __ ] up
I'm coming to stay with you for a few
days so I get straight and then I got to
go clean up and you know he says Christ
you sound like slash yeah well so what
can unbelievers old - I was 21 years old
right can I just pause it for one second
now all you guys who no one you know
listen to this podcast a lot and I talk
about my early days of stand-up I swear
to God mark when I started stand-up in
Boston Massachusetts I started to do
well the amount of headliners I would
say like 65% of the headliners that I
worked with in my first three years
their opening line to their set was so
I've been sober for six months yeah
everybody was in [ __ ] AAA everybody
had cleaned up and and half of those
guys were were what should gum dude on
them like they're the the half of those
guys were like like their wages were
getting garnished by the IRS sure they
were reckon like four grand others guys
like Sweeney and yeah I don't want to
name names yeah that's one of the things
on the podcast we don't name names I've
got to tell you that [ __ ] so they
basically yeah like these guys had
[ __ ] you know they've been making
four grand cash every [ __ ] weekend
right
years and didn't pay a dime in taxes
right and then all of them basically
couldn't leave Massachusetts unless they
got a written note from the IRS
yeah or some [ __ ] so by the time I came
in the rebellious thing to do was to go
on stage sober if it was kind it was
well this way I shouldn't say rebellious
it was the norm so when I came in and
the guys I started out with and I
mentioned names here just because I'm
not saying anything bad but I started
off with Dane and Patrice and like those
guys just didn't drink and I came from
like me and my friends were a bunch of
booze bags yeah and when I came in they
didn't drink and I saw how [ __ ] up
these guys were you know who Minds out
yeah and and and you know and some of
them had some regret not all of them but
some of them were I should have done it
yeah so I immediately equated with Oh
getting [ __ ] up is stupid and so I
started my whole career I started off
you know work totally clean and I would
and I was and I was totally sober and
then [ __ ] this year I had to actually
go on the wagon for like two and a half
months I don't know what happened
touring touring did it to me no it
breaks you down it's a tough racket but
you know I mean I always wanted to be
that I mean I you know before I got to
LA I always wanted to be you know I all
my heroes were [ __ ] up we were [ __ ]
up you know all my heroes are you know
all the comics you know everyone I
respect why is it so romantic that that
whole [ __ ] it's because I'm sitting I'm
sitting there going like even as [ __ ]
up as that story is I'm sitting there
like feeling like I'm like show business
light because I don't have any stories
of being up for [ __ ] three days and
and and I'm old enough to know I don't
want those [ __ ] stories but you just
don't want to have a boring
autobiography you know when you do that
when the comedian when you finally hit
and they give you the book deal and you
got to have you know your head on your
hand like well you know that might take
on life the truth the matter is is that
you know it doesn't help you and you
know and if you stay doing that it will
kill you there's no way around it that
no but you want to have a couple of
buckets that's a great story
oh there's another story when I was
hanging out with Sam Thomas everyone at
AAA meetings just to [ __ ] listen to
yeah he shouldn't Tommy Lee I mean I've
been sober over ten years over ten years
just you haven't done anything no I you
know I got I got straight got into the
program you know you know learned how to
rewire my brain I've done nothing
I'm a sober guy ten years but you know
whatever yeah but you know you're a cool
sober guy because I don't even know that
about you I mentioned it something like
tonight to get going yeah you know I was
I you know I didn't drink for two and a
half months and then I went to England
was like I got to try these beers and
beers and now I'm like bummed when I go
three [ __ ] days and I was like [ __ ] I
was up to like 75 and then all the
sudden just got real seriously cuz you
want to get sober like really like
looking into my soul and my Jesus Christ
dude no I'm not like that
no the only question is is like look you
know I don't care what anyone does you
know and I certainly appreciate the
process of drinking and boozing and
doing drugs I loved it but you know it
really just comes down to if you get to
that point the only time you need to get
sober really is if you all of a sudden
you'll try to stop and you can't or your
life becomes unmanageable that's it you
know and then that's when you need help
that's it alright now this is where I'm
at I'm stuck I have stopped and done you
know but I I don't want to stop it's not
that I can't I like it like last night
I'm sitting there doing the gig it was a
place I always wanted to perform at I
[ __ ] destroyed
I even yelled out a Blues Brothers line
yeah that John Belushi said on stage in
the minoan got it but I did it for me
yes that a [ __ ] great time you know
and afterwards I got this big ice chest
of [ __ ] Heinekens just staring at me
and I didn't drink one because I knew
that you know I didn't want one I wanted
to wanted to drink all of them and then
stuff my face into the ice when I was
done so III I liked it the way I like
cookies I want to eat the whole [ __ ]
bag alright so then you know what that's
called
what's that alcoholism know what is I
kidding no let's tell me that look if
the bottom line is you can do it however
you want you know yeah it's like a lot
of people you have to understand
something about people in the program is
that most of them you know who are
especially gung-ho about it it saved
their [ __ ] life and it does every
[ __ ] day that's it you know and it's
you know that's really interesting so
now I'll be more forgiving of somebody
who you know they're like fanatics of
any kind but they're not trying to push
Jesus on me I mean part of the program
is really it's based on helping other
alcoholics so they actually when they do
that it's it's in a way you know you
know in terms of the way the program
works it's helping them see it teaches
pathologically self-centered people who
can't control themselves to behave like
like right
people by helping other people in a very
specific way so yeah that's it yeah I
mean it's not usually they don't it's
not a hard line thing and no one's ever
gonna come up to you like that you know
why I've actually really though
monitored my drinking's because I'm so
[ __ ] vain I like the the face looks a
lot better when you drink when I don't
Oh cuz when I don't because I know
however you want that you know the thing
is it's like if it's not destroying your
wife so be it and if you want to go up
and down and quit here and there and
here if it's not destroying your life
that's it yeah like after I go do this
my Easter dinner is gonna be I'm gonna
go to somebody's house and watch gonna
watch the Red Sox Yankees it's great now
how to [ __ ] no one's telling you not to
the thing is it really comes down to in
light of what you're talking about if
you've tried to stop with all your heart
over and over again because you want to
stop drinking over and you can't right
then then it's something to be addressed
if you want to take a break but you like
to drink but it's not ruining your life
and you're just a weird kind of
controlling guy in your mind and you're
like [ __ ] I had two months you know but
if it's not a plague [ __ ] it
this is this is what's killing me I had
a buddy of mine he quit for a minute and
I swear to God like he's one of these
guys who quit I might do what the [ __ ]
'ya quitting for you don't have a
problem okay this guy quit for like
maybe 17 days and I think he lost about
30 pounds and I was like Jax is Christ
yeah you were [ __ ] boozing and he
looked great yet he you know he look
like he look like an Oscar but that's
exact I can't wait to hit him with that
when he if you didn't if you knew this
guy yeah you look literally like his
body the silhouette of an Oscar and and
then one day call me I and I start
drinking and I realized I didn't have a
problem I just was drinking too much and
blah blah so now he's back on a drinkin
okay I saw him again and dude he looked
like [ __ ] hell it looked like he got
run over by a bus man terrible tricky
business
it's a tricky [ __ ] man yeah like he just
look he you know he looked like when he
stopped drinking for three weeks
you know those [ __ ] shows I do a
makeover yeah we're gonna give you a new
hip haircut we're gonna give you a shiny
shirt and all the sudden you come
walking up yeah yeah and I know all of a
sudden the women start paying that's
that's what he look like he came down to
the club in
my girlfriend was like Jesus look at you
Wow and this is the thing about him he
didn't go to the [ __ ] gym
he just stopped drinking yeah so that is
the one aspect of it is my face look
better and then one girl told me that my
skin looked great
yeah so that's you know I'm so [ __ ] that
keeps you so I'm so insecure yeah and so
[ __ ] vain I'm like well you I can't
drink my mother my skin is looking great
right now yeah yeah I I'm with you on
that I mean I used to talk I talk about
it a lot you know in a sense on stage
and how it is I mean like I said it's
just I'm happy I lived through it
because there's a there's periods there
you know whatever anyone thinks you know
either that's your life and that's the
lifestyle you want to live or you're
gonna make a drastic change or you just
deal with the ups and downs of it but I
used to say when I got somebody to say
you know the great thing about sobriety
is how clearly you can see your
disappointment thing I was joking about
is how [ __ ] long a year is yeah when
you're sober
it's like I remember every second of
this other than when I was sleeping it's
like it was like February I can't
believe is not May yet yes it's [ __ ]
insane I like that though I as I get
older I had much rather time just drip
by than rush by hannes brutal I don't
even want to have in those last [ __ ]
decades I think I think we're getting
closer what are we up to there on your
computer I have no idea no 3:20 what
time did we start about 250 yeah we
might be a little bit over now you want
to do it yeah well let me let me let me
give a chance here you listening to Marc
Maron I just for the future when I do
these interviews so it's always
uncomfortable giving other comedians
compliments where we were such
self-loathing people but I think
seriously Marc for my for my money
you've always been when the book one of
the [ __ ] best comics in the country
so if Marc is coming to your area
definitely go see him he does not pander
to the audience he says what the [ __ ] he
wants to say I think you're [ __ ]
awesome and every comic from here on out
if they're on my show they fit that bill
I don't know if they'll be able to
follow your stories but every once in a
while we're gonna do this on the podcast
I'm gonna have a comedian that I really
admire and admired your work for a long
time so how about let me know some of
the gigs or my listeners know where
you're gonna be
you got anything coming up well yeah
this week I'm going to be in Tempe
Arizona at the
madcap theatres you can go to madcap
theatres calm that's this weekend if
you're dropping this today this is
Monday and I'll be with Eddie Pepitone
madcap theatres calm Friday and Saturday
I'll be at the Bridgetown Comedy
Festival in Portland Portland Oregon ok
and then in April the end of April be a
Comics in New York with Garofalo oh
that's a huge show good deal man and I
now in also - podcast podcast WTF with
Marc Maron you can get at WTF pod comm
or you can just go to iTunes and look up
WTF there's a Bilborough episode on
there and a lot of your favorite comics
on there all of them are on there oh
there you go man alright that's been the
Monday morning podcasts a very special
Monday morning podcast from the Marc
Maron bunker out here in LA hope you
guys all had a nice Easter and enjoy
your week
[Music]